[Music]
hi
and welcome to another night of chess on
psychology
today i decided to come to the chess
club and dress up a little bit
because well i'm very happy with my
performance in the us championship
so i kind of wanted to come here
and just kind of celebrate it a little
bit with you guys because
yeah you guys saw me do chess throughout
all this pandemics struggle with studies
and everything
so i feel like i owe you guys that that
little bit
of celebration so here we are sitting
and
um this beautiful studio b
and i actually do have to pull up my
games i kind of forgot to do that
um but ah there alright there i am yeah
this was a particular so i want to talk
to you a little about the events because
it was a very
um it was very unexpected like i i
surprised myself
with the results but the truth is i
don't actually
have that much of a hard time um
like finding the moves because the way
i've been teaching you guys
and my private students and the way i've
just been doing chess
is um well to be honest lazy chess
i'm not doing that much um
i try to avoid calculation because i'm
not
um not like that strong in it because
i don't do professional chess anymore
don't tell that to my coach but that's
the whole point because i try to avoid
calculation i come up with the most
practical and most logical moves and i
will i calculate it a little bit
like i make sure that there is nothing
horribly wrong with it except for the
round that i just
gifted my knight but
my yeah that was that was a sad round
but uh besides that
um every single other game i was just
trying to be practical i was trying to
annoy my opponent and i was just trying
to
um just make the game as hard as
possible for my opponent to want to play
it
and that kind of worked i think another
thing that was to my advantage was
because i was uh for i wasn't one of the
the real competitors like from going in
the tournament i wasn't one of the
people who
someone would bet on i don't think i
would bet on myself for winning the
tournament
um i think that a lot of these players
underestimated me and because i don't
really play professional
uh competitive chess there's um they
kind of imagined that
i wouldn't remember how to but they
forgot that i've been doing chess with
you guys
all throughout like last six or seven
months
so i think that has had a big impact on
me so
i do owe a huge thank you to the saint
louis chess club
for having me teach this much
and to you guys for keeping me motivated
to come up with better material and show
up
so thank you everybody and
um definitely a huge thanks to the cat
obviously for
for being cute so another thing that i
wanted to slightly clarify
i don't know if you i see a little bit
of in the chat about my cat jumping
he was jumping when i had one minute on
the clock that that scene was middle of
the game
he wasn't uh he wasn't he didn't do that
after the game i had one minute
and he that that specific round he was
so
noisy and impatient and that
that specific round i was just like oh
my god tata was gonna complain because
um
she probably could have heard and i was
like if she complains she has every
right to i don't know what i'm gonna say
besides i'm so sorry i have a
weird cat he's being playful but
like i had one mat and he was just
jumping all around so
once i like i tried to stop him and then
he fell down and he just ran away
and then he was quiet for that but yeah
thank you thank you for all of your uh
positivity and support yeah
exactly uh
yeah uh that's that that that
um yeah it was a lovely tournament for
me but yeah that that little cat scene
oh my god
he was so um i don't know if i don't
think
the viewers had access to what the
arbiters were saying
but the secondary camera was like right
behind and it was showing the desk and
on top of the desk
and like i had this little thing on top
of my desk
that i'm supposed to put books but i put
the cat
and he was sleeping up there all the
tournament pretty much
and i would like play with his paws
middle of the game or like pet him a
little
which was really good like that was a
really positive thing
and um so if he had a cat make sure that
if he stays quiet to use him
use his cuteness during the tournament
but okay so um
that was a really funny thing for me
that i've never actually i've never
actually played with two cameras
so i first i had a weird setup i was but
like after that the setup has
got better i got a set i got a laptop
from the club and
my my uh greenish camera also got better
so yeah that was a that was a funny
first day
but yeah yeah i'm very glad with my
uh with my tournament i think it went
pretty well i can't imagine it having
gone any better
but full disclosure for those of you who
have already seen the games and know
how it went on at the the round before
the last one the game against talia
when it ended in a draw i started crying
because
i knew i was winning i knew i was lost
in that first and then i was winning and
i couldn't win it
and i kind of knew if i wanted i would
still not get first but it would still
be
more competitive so i was very under
pressure on that and i started crying
and
i don't know if that showed up on the
camera or there is a weird footage of
that
for somewhere in the the the truck
but yeah that happened so if you are a
choir
join the club but yeah and then after
that when i was like sobbing to my mom
she was like why are crying even if you
lose your last run you're thought
tied for third and i was like oh oh okay
i guess i'm gonna stop crying
yeah so that was a little background
story
on the the games on the whole tournament
as well all right so i'm just gonna show
you some of the the really cool ones
that i liked because
we're not gonna go over every single one
of them
uh i did go over them a little bit on
twitch channel
if you are interested i'm sure you can
find that on friday
so also i know that's probably hebrew
i do not speak it unfortunately i think
it's a
very cute language that i know nothing
about
all right so i want to show you my first
uh
let's uh probably should go the other
way okay i'm still a newbie on leeches
just the chess websites keeps on
switching and switching
yeah i did have talia was a rough one
yeah i could have easily lost that game
she could have easily beat me she could
have easily eat
beats um crush so talia is a very
very tough opponent yeah
um ah thank you i'm glad to see you here
all right so i want to show you whoa
that's a new setup here
uh the first game that i had against
sabina cause that was kind of a defying
moment for me because i so last time i
played this championship i didn't really
have the best tournament i'm just gonna
leave it at that
so um i my goal playing this torrent was
just to
finish no it wasn't my goal to be in top
three i because you didn't even dream of
it so i'm being honest
um i just wanted to end up somewhere
between like
five to eight i thought if that happens
that's perfect i just want to be like in
the middle because
um well there are many other players
here who
are much better players than me and
they're much more devoted to chess than
me
so i um yeah
i um one of the big revolutions i had
this year
and i realized i'm talking a little too
much
um was that i watched a lot of
eric rosen's videos and he's such an
awesome personality
he i like i really enjoyed how
everybody had this positive view of him
that he doesn't say
what he doesn't like he doesn't lie
about his dreams he doesn't say oh i
want to be grandmaster i want to be like
in top five in the world he doesn't say
stuff like that when most other chess
players do
and so i realized though why because
before that i used to be like yeah most
likely
at some point we're gonna i was playing
it's a little safe
so yeah i thought that was a i thought
that was a big lesson for me so
i guess a little thank you to him as
well but okay
so let's get to some chess um i believe
this game
was the one against subpoena the first
round um
yeah um so
uh in this in this specific tournament i
had a bunch of games who
i was uh already um kind of
out prepared within the first five moves
but this was not one of them
surprisingly
um i kind of so full disclosure i
i used to be elsian's students back in
2011-12
so i kind of have an understanding of
how he thinks
to prepare for someone and since they
are
engaged i assumed that well of course
she would help her prepare
and also with an understanding of her
games
i kind of expected london i because
i'm supposed to be an easy one to beat
so she wouldn't want to play these
boring dry lines when i play super
boring dry stuff
so she wouldn't want to go into that so
she would want something sharp
and um that's why she played this london
and i fully expected this
and i had prepared this specific line
with bishop d6
so the whole idea of bishop d6 is it's
not that hard i just want to play e5 man
that's all i want to do and um however
i was not really prepared for this queen
e2 idea
and up here i realized well
if i don't do knight e4 he's gonna
she's gonna play knight e4 and i really
don't want to deal with that
so lazy chess um
yeah so london could get pretty sharp
actually and the way
i have games in london the games that i
have in database on london
they are pretty different
so i think that was her preparation she
expected me to be surprised by her
london and play what i
know already so she i would get into her
preparation
but instead i knew she i kind of had a
feeling she was going to play london i
prepared something else and then we
ended up in my preparation
so i guess that's how it went
and um so i know that here there are
possibilities of like taking and then
playing something like c5 or so
but i really didn't want to deal with e4
another thing is this is a pretty um
it's not a very easy thing for me to say
but
um in all girls tournament activity is
for like for most girls um woman's
uh having that peace activity is very
crucial like if you give me a position
that i like and i i'm active in i'm
gonna play like a 2400.
but if you give me a position that i
actually have to use my skills and my
chest understanding
and i can't just attack then my rating
goes down to 2200.
so that's kind of why i think that's
true with
lots of the women which is very sad and
that's i think why there's this huge
rating gap that chess understanding
because
attacking is usually easier than
actually
finding the right move when both players
are praying
playing well but again don't quote me on
that because
it's a very painful thing to say anyways
so this was another idea to do but i
really didn't want to deal with the
e4 stuff the london um
has a bad uh i don't think so i don't
think london has it well
uh i keep clicking on zero i don't think
london has a bad reputation
i think um any opening can have a bad
reputation
in really high level chess but
this was not a very high level chest it
was a very good level chess
but with sabine and i are both
similar in rating so
i have not watched the queen's gambit do
not give me spoilers
i do want to watch it but i have to get
my studying back on track
that is what i plan to do next week the
next weekend
but actually this upcoming weekend okay
so let me just
get the get a little going with this
game
oh wow i didn't know we just had this
setup
huh okay um so
as i just mentioned i need active
position i need an attack
so obviously f5 was the first thing i
thought about
when knight d2 should be the first thing
i think about
um so i just feel like that's the whole
concept
of um it really it really
shows how you can play better in the
positions that you like better
so f5 i don't think
too many grandmasters would choose this
move
but good thing i wasn't playing with one
um to me f5 was very natural because i'm
going to cast on i'm going to try and
get this knight up here i'm going to try
to create some sort of attack
yeah kind of like that i believe so liam
i didn't really like the idea that i
could give white the chance to play e4
and i was naturally gonna go for that so
i simply uh got myself into this
position i believe this is a very
decent position for black
it's kind i've played dutch so it
doesn't really feel like that because i
always play it with
e5 f5 and e5 but it's a very interesting
position nevertheless
so i got to this position
all right so right now um i want to do a
little questionnaire
uh do you guys want to be white or black
and potentially why
has better space but that e4 pawn could
become problematic in long run
yeah i see that yeah i think here
correctly um
i don't think white is necessarily
better or worse i do think that both
both sides have a good fighting chance
but i do like the activity
for black because
if i could kick this knight away if i
could somehow join a b5 and get this
file then that would actually be pretty
active and that's what i went for i
brought the rook
i kicked the knight and
so in this position actually
um from what
i understand black is doing fine
but you have to be very cautious because
you have to actually find accurate moves
as black
and surprisingly the best move um
i believe it's queen a6 or queen b6
so my idea was i just want to double up
the rooks
and in order to do that i can't just
play rook c7 because this pawn will fall
take the rook takes queen takes and the
pawn will fall right
so i can't really do that so i uh
i have to play it a little smarter so
the same way i was just telling you guys
my
lovely lazy chest um
i uh i kind of avoided calculations and
i was okay so the problem is that my
pawn is weak so let's defend the pawn
but this was actually a blunder can
somebody tell me
why and for in order to actually find
the reason you actually have to
calculate
and that is why i missed it
so what do you guys think black to white
to move
how can you punish black for playing a6
and while you're thinking i'm going to
went a little about my
me pulling my first all-nighter studying
of the year but of the semester
yeah i um underestimated how much
studying i had to do for my today's
cancer biology exam
so i pulled an all-nighter i actually
took a
two hour nap at the chest room in saint
louis university
because i was studying there and it was
painful my back kind of hurts
but things i went pretty decent i think
should be fine
but yeah first all-nighter of the
semester
so i actually don't see anybody um
saying the exact
move so i'm just going to go ahead and
say it because i do want to get to other
games
am i a psychology major surprisingly no
i do appreciate psychology
but um i'm a little bit more into the
the to the actual science of it not that
psychology isn't the science
i just feel like i need to see things
um oh thank you whoa liam nice
okay good job yeah basically take or
it's safer to take over here first and
then take over here
and then queen g4 and i would be pretty
whooped
because i can't really get out of this
position i've lost the pawn already
and my rook is defenseless my knight is
defenseless
and to be honest these are my nightmare
positions i try my best not to have
defenseless pieces so
this position i completely missed knight
e4 and luckily for me
so did she she played h3 i don't really
understand the
idea behind this i guess to avoid knight
g4s
um and here i made another lovely
mistake okay oh
well all right here i made
another lovely mistake and i
simply played rook c7 i was just
following my plan i just wanted to play
rook c7 or c8 and double up
um if you do knight e4 right
i don't think knight d4 is wrong because
even it4
i think knight e4 take
i think this should be the exact same
thing actually
unless there is a there's a take i i
don't think take as well either because
then you just
simply lose the activity of this file as
well
yeah i don't think i guess there is a
much difference actually
oh uh mark mars markin
i have not but that sounds like a very
very interesting
book to read
[Music]
so okay a6 h3
apparently according to computer h6 was
better
i do not know why
i can only uh why can't he do the same
thing
oh i have knight g5 okay never mind yeah
i'll just have knight g5 and knight g5
is defending this and
voila now this is winning for black
white just gave up the piece for no
reason ah
smart okay so if i actually saw knight
e4 in the game i would most likely see
h6 as well
because if you have seen any of my
streams you kind of know my
my thought process that i don't
um again like i'm not exactly the
sharpest when it comes to calculation
but when i spot something i can like if
i see the problem i can easily find the
solution
so if the problem is that the knight and
the pawn are hanging and i don't have
knight g5 h6 is the move that makes
sense
so all right h3 or c7 oh boy
and i want this i
had very very generous opponents
i'm not going to lie about that they
were very friendly they kept giving me
chances to win
so in this position i remember
i was like okay so i'm not going to play
boring queen d7 because queen d7 queen
goes to c2 and i'm already worse
uh jasper women and men already do
compete in the same tournaments
so the problem isn't that women can't
play
as good as just as men that's not the
problem because when you put a
2400 2200 woman next to 2200 men
the that 2200 women usually have
much more much more just understanding
than between 200 men because
well she works more on chess because in
her in
in women's that 200 2300 is a higher
world ranking than than that 2200 man
so in the same rating category i do
believe that women are usually
a little bit more
educated but the problem is that for
example you look at the us championship
the average rating
of the top 10 is different that's why
women don't
exactly play in the in the high level
men tournaments not that big
it's not that because they're women
because the chest level is
less and that is very painful to
actually say out loud
and exactly thank you liam less women
play chess so
yeah i i agree with that um the if you
look at the statistics um
i saw actually i saw this uh on fide
that posted the like 10
of all chess players are female and i
was like
well that sounds lovely so you can see
the
the uh the problem easily oh and thank
you yeah i
um thank you owen all right so queen f7
my idea in this position was that okay
well i gotta go after her king because
i'm not gonna win in this line in this
file she already has that file if i keep
fighting for that i'm gonna lose really
horribly
so i played queen f7 knight to a5 i
think my t5 was a little too chill she
should have played a little
uh more aggressively and after knight a5
at this point i was like okay so i have
two choices
i can either channel my brother and play
g5
or my teammates who are big fan of g5s
or i can channel um
my inner logic and be like okay so you
gotta play here
my inner defense and just play like rook
c8 and just sit there and try for a draw
and i was just like yeah i want to play
g5 especially because this tournament
uh specifically was a chill tournament
for me up until
like when i cried that the round before
the last
because well i didn't really expect much
from myself
and um i just was trying to have fun
and g5 looked more interesting than
queen d7
and so i went for g5 yeah
um i don't exactly recommend that to
always play for fun
but yeah i that was kind of my
um my way of
this tournament it kind of paid off but
again
every single one of the games that it
could have gone completely different way
i don't know suzanne ordered it
personally
i was very angry at him i had one minute
and the furry fluff kept just
jumping on and off i had one minute i
was so scared he was gonna like walk on
the laptop and do a move for me
um all right so
i think rook d6 was her last mistake
again
you see if i i don't think here sabina
was being objective because if she was
she wouldn't really take on d6 because
again because i'm supposedly a
easier opponent to beat i think that's
why she took she played this because
this is not what the actual position
needs
it's not what her position is actually
telling her
um so i feel like that was a that was
her mistake that she underestimated me
and i would really love to get her
opinion on that
but i think i'm gonna wait maybe a few
weeks before i contact my opponents who
i beat
um anyways um
here according to what engine
said uh f3 or f4 or g5 or queens t2
where some of the ways that white could
have tried to get away
from this attack because my idea is
pretty simple again again
you see there's not much calculations
exactly they were all giving me
opportunities exactly so whoops not with
that pawn i want to take here i want to
play queen
and i'm going to go wild so i don't
exactly know how i was going to
find the mates but i knew that word in
my next two moves
so um after she took on d6
that move already felt very wrong again
i didn't have
every single move calculated when i take
on g4 but i knew that this night
all the way over there and this rook all
the way over there it's like
they're in like disney world and i'm
there trying to
to deal with real life stuff exactly
drink d6 is it was a trip terrible
blunder
which i don't think again she would have
done if she was playing
anyone else and so
and that's my idea um to just get
checkmate
uh okay this is also uh uh i'm gonna
share my thought process with you after
king f1
it was a very interesting way now so
up until this point okay i knew i was
better but
i did not exactly believe that i was
winning
just because i haven't actually um
last time we played with sabina it ended
in a draw and
she is a she was she's like a defending
champion from 2017 so
she has already won this tournament when
i haven't
last time i played i don't want to talk
about it it wasn't a pretty tournament
um so right here
the little bit of psychology behind it i
started thinking okay
so what does my position have and i
didn't really have that much time on my
clock
i was simply trying to figure out what's
the easiest way to play this because
if i play rook f2 i don't really want to
get into that position because i mean it
looks
better i have a queen against the brook
and a knight but
it didn't exactly feel
that winning um
i think the biggest problem was that
again i didn't
completely trust that i could win that
and i didn't want her to get away with
it
so i started thinking what else can i do
and i realized um
queen h5 looks pretty interesting
queenish five
queenish five king e1 czech
queen f1 and at this point
i did not find the best move so i gave
up on my calculations
uh ah thank you ben simon for that
description
i completely zoned out of that
conversation uh
but up at this point uh
i'm not queen h5 my thought process was
okay what about check let's think about
checks so knight h2 if the king goes to
g1
i have perpetual and then i said i have
perpetual i remember i was talking to
myself i was like wait but
if i give check that's not a perpetual
king goes to there it's checkmate
and if check king g1 check king that
goes back to f1 i can't just have queen
h5 so that wins
and then i so i started thinking about a
perpetual and then i
flanded in oh but that's mate
so that's kind of uh i think that was a
little embarrassing because i knew i was
winning but i was still like
a part of me was still not believing it
um so i did this knight h2 and it's um
if king goes to e1 queen takes g2 it's a
it's an easy peasy i want to do knight
f3 type of deal or
just queen g1 rook f2 um
so here she played f1 okay now i knew i
was definitely winning because i just
take it over here
attacking the queen you got i thought if
you take well that's also easy
queen f2 and i was like okay so i can
take it and then i can give check and i
can push or i can just point knight g4
and be a little mean
so i did that and she resigned here um
it was a very very it was like
i think this game was the defying game
for me because
if i started uh if i started off with a
loss i don't
know if i would come back from that
exactly
but so it's really important how you
start your tournament at least
in this tournament for me was very
important um
yeah i don't exactly understand that the
idea of knight a5
either i don't think the knight belongs
on a5 all right i really want to talk
about
my last game as oh let me just show you
this little cute position
that i gave up my lovely night
um i'm just showing you the final
position
so i'm just showing you that even if you
blunder
you are still capable of playing good
chess
maybe just not in that game so in this
game
right now it's black to move um i was
playing emily
she played jerk a8 and i was like okay
so i had enough time on my clock i was
like 10 minutes i had 10 minutes or so
almost 10 minutes or something and i
knew that my position is not
very great because of this pawn and
because the
well knight before is coming and then
the other knight will jump here
and i don't exactly love my position
but so the one move that i
was probably not supposed to do was
knight c6 and guess what
i did it um
exactly and the thing was with knight c6
i thought you take
i have knight take c7 knight take c7 i
have rook b8
i thought i was going to b8 not to c8
because the previous move my rick was on
b1 and i played the trick to c1 so
just wanted to show this awesome blunder
and
um just to give you a little bit of hope
that if you have
weird weird weird games you still can
make it
back all right now let me show you the
actual
good games ah this game was awesome i
think this game was one of my
masterpieces i really enjoyed this game
so
uh this is the game against anna
zatonski i'm not going to spend too much
time on it because i do want to get to
the game that i had against tatev as
well
um but in this game with anna zatonski
she's such a she's such a nice person
and such a
great great chess player and so
um i've already lost her once before
so it wasn't exactly my um
my top choice to play
her i couldn't actually do anything
about it though
so i i looked at her openings uh before
the game obviously and i knew
i kind of like saw that okay she played
this line a few times
and i had a feeling she was going to
play something with either queen a7 or
either b6
because she had um moves she had um
she had some uh games like that
um so queen d7
i knew what i was doing i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna
down uh downplayed i had prepared this
even to a little extent so i knew that
okay i'm gonna get the queen to g3 and i
knew that this knight belongs to f4 i
don't think that's very hard to actually
figure out
um oh thank you kevin um so i think that
was a very interesting choice ah you say
that now but this
this game was not boring man i'm gonna
show you
so uh how was my winning rate
with white versus black hot that's a
good that's a good question
so i beat sabine with black i beat um
[Music]
annie wang with black and i believe i
beat
tatev uh jennifer
and anna with white
so
yeah oh thank you that's very nice of
you a lot of a lot of
a lot of great positivity in the chat
thank you
daniel and um njm
i'm sorry i can't pronounce that i do
appreciate your message though
where is the live chat i mean
the live chat is here
uh yeah i was i was impressed with my
own game man
so um let me i actually really wanted to
show this
so before the game when i was looking at
this position
my um my
my my preparation well my files let's
just say because i wasn't actually
actively looking appliance just the
things i had in the file
was like okay the knight has to go back
to ba to play like knight f4
there and there is this like wild line
here
or something like that i believe this
was something and then the queen goes to
g6 and then there's a long
like this was one of the lines that i
uh it was mentioned in the book but i
don't think this actually holds that
much for black
either but it was just interesting to
look at it anyways
um so i kind of knew that i had this
idea of knight to 496 up my sleeve
but then she long castled and i was like
ha well long cast though the only way i
can form any sort of attack is to push
this pawn to a5 so
let's first do that a4 a5
well i got to take this because if i
play a6 that that doesn't make any sense
and now um i believe this was opposite
i think here i started thinking should i
play bishop a3 first
oops and then play bishop d6 and then i
realized that i really really
really don't want to deal with in this
knight on c4
uh carlos i think so i'm not exactly
sure
oh do i follow a certain diet yes i
forget to eat
and then i binge on a lot of food and
then i go into food comas
that has been happening a lot i need to
fix that
but okay so in this position i kind of
wanted to uh
touch up on this idea a little bit
because well if black gets knight c4 or
black is kind of holding the position
so as white you have to make a decision
do you actually care about
this stroke that much or do you want to
attack
and my thought was like i really don't
know how to kick this knight off c4 and
i really don't want to get into
unpleasant positions
ah let's take it and i'm not kidding you
that was exactly the way i thought
of er let's take it and
and then i was like well this is a very
and uh this is interesting so
uh i got a lot of feedback ah thank you
thank you for your donation
oh that's very nice of you uh
it was a very great tournament thank you
um i was talking to one of my private
students
he's such a cute kid and i i was showing
him this game and i asked him so
do you want to take it and i was like
yeah i'll probably take it
and then i asked him so what is your
next move because i wanted to see if the
moves i was doing was like a
super grandmaster level or was it
understandable level because to me these
are normal moves
and um then the skin is also about 1200
and he was like well i got to do
something with my bishop maybe let's go
to g5 and i said but if bishop g5
there's 97 i was like yeah you're right
let's get this bishop d6 get the rook to
be one let's do this checkmate
that was an easy like my 1200 kid saw it
so let's get that bishop there but now i
have a new target like just
looking at this king and queen my first
it's like my
um i watched a lot of cartoons growing
up and right now
um like this would be the moment that
that cartoon character would get like
the dollar sign in his
eyes but it's not exactly dollar signs i
would get like a horse sign
in my eyes with like night i just want
to get this beautiful knight to see
to c5 and i believe she made a mistake
here with playing knight h6
but i don't think i didn't really feel
like that was a mistake in the game i
kind of knew that knight on h6 isn't
doing much anyways
how would you deal with that pawn on c3
i'm gonna play c4 and i'm gonna get rid
of it
great question am i even reading the
chat i
am why wouldn't i if i wasn't going to
read the chat then
that would kind of make this class
pointless
so yeah at this point i realized well
i think knight d3 is also a pretty nice
move
but then the king kind of goes to a8 and
i can't really reach it
so that's why i was like well
all of my pieces are have a purpose
except for this queen
because if i play knight d3 then my
queen can't get in and i can't really
play queen d3 right now because
then where am i going with my queen so i
think this was where
c4 made sense and
i only calculated as much as c4 if take
i do rook b1
king if king ga8 there's queen f3 and i
thought if
if king goes to a6 well the king on i6
looks pretty weird should be made soon
and um yeah i was really
lazy calculating so take check
king went to a6 and here i was like oh
wait
i have my d3 and i think knight d3 was a
very
very interesting move knight e6 instead
of c4
i'll get to that in a second now d3 was
a very interesting move because if you
take well
i'm just gonna do checkmate in like two
moves
let me check this idea with knight e6 ha
but what is your purpose because queen
takes and i guess queen g7
is what you're going for but there's
like a knight f7
even if there was no knight f7 the queen
is defending h6 even if the queen wasn't
defending h6
it doesn't really go to the uh it
doesn't really go
to the um same pathway that's
i was going like i'm taking all my
pieces to the queen side
um don diego i do respond to the youtube
chats
when i see comments and questions i'll
definitely respond why not
why else am i sitting here um
96 after the king has moved
um well
oh we just you guys just want to
sacrifice for the sake of it that's all
i was trying to do too
but just like the right way you know i'm
not just shooting out sacrifices like
the cute ways like
kind of like catch me if you can style
because well that would be a lovely
checkmate i think this would be so
beautiful
yeah i do have to close the deal if i'm
i mean i'm running out of pieces i can't
just keep giving stuff up
and right now i wanted to check my 101
knight to c5
so i i got a lot of
very lovely comments on like uh saying
like how great i played and i was like
especially on this game with zatonski
and i didn't know how to say i was just
trying to do checkmating once
i don't think that would have been very
um professional
um yeah so
knight d3 well yeah i think knight d3
comes with
just like trying to constantly question
yourself and i have gotten
pretty good at questioning myself um
maybe a little too good so yeah
um after this now i have a new target
i want to take queen somehow on c4
that's my next move that's my next idea
and so now what else are we going to do
well
let's go for another check maintain one
and it was interesting because uh when i
was talking to alejandro alejandro
ramirez is my coach my team coach from
saint louis
he's awesome a very dear friend of mine
he's such a nice character he's always
happy always smiling
maybe not today but
he's overall a very positive personality
a very positive person
and he he was telling me you did um that
i played
uh perfect moves for like 10 moves
in a row and i was like well it was all
threatening mating once i don't think
there is any better
move than threatening meeting one so
that was a very
um that was a very funny thing
ah why did you play queen a4 well i was
threatening
maintain one i wasn't kidding when i
said i'm threatening meeting once
um yeah so after here brook c7
guys you are really in the mood to give
up every single piece aren't you
um so rook c7
uh it was a very interesting idea
because
well my bishop is kind of not doing
anything here anymore
so i had to kind of compromise and
figure out what i want to do with this
bishop and then i saw this idea of
bishop d6 maybe queen b8 queen c8 so i
played with bishop d6
and then i realized well even if i play
queen b8 it's still a pretty i mean i
still am much better but queen c6
and the queen is still kind of taking
over my position and i didn't like how
this queen
is um defending all of these squares and
i didn't really see
how to win that guys bishop a7 is not a
good move
um bishop is actually i mean it's doable
but the problem isn't that it takes it
the problem is that queen comes to c6
so we don't want to give black
chances if you have been with me for
some of our lectures you probably have
heard me
just saying that i want to annoy the
opponent and i don't want to give my
opponent the chance to escape
so if you give white if you give black
like two moves black is gonna play like
a queen back to c6
and it's gonna start bringing this
knight back and start defending so you
can't
just chill and just you can't you have
to play
actively you have to constantly have
threats
and what's better threat than i'm coming
after your rook
and d5 is such a great move it takes
away all of the queen c6 ideas
right uh i
don't think when b6 was the winning move
i think d5 here is another winning move
but
bishop d6 is the best idea followed up
with d5
and the thing is that well i want to
take over here and then your rook
actually has nowhere to go
so that's the fun about it well maybe
not for anna but this was the whole
point that your rook doesn't have
anywhere to go
and even if you take i still have
another pawn e6
and now when you move this rook um
so i think something like i don't
actually
i don't i don't think black can get out
of this uh engine is not also
giving me much to work with in this
position
uh well you can't take because the haha
checkmate
you can't really move the rook anywhere
in this um
this line because i will take it
there was nowhere that queen b6 was
working guys
what if anna tried to trade queens i
think that would have been a reasonable
way to do it but you can't do that the
bishop is on b4
protecting i got a question about
the difference between uh why why people
play
why women and men play in different
categories i already mentioned that
before because
it's not because women play worse chess
than men
it's because in the same level like you
look at the two and twenty three hundred
and one twenty three hundred ma'am that
twenty three hundred women
usually have more chess knowledge well
same age let's go the same age as well
but
um the problem is that less women play
chess uh actually one out of ten
it's like 10 10 men one woman
the ratio actually in the world
so
if you look at the rating averages i
would say that the rating average for
u.s women championship i don't have the
exact but i'm gonna guess like maybe 23
50. uh for men it would be more like
2600
26.50 so that's why it's not
that's why it wouldn't be a fair
tournament
um so
yeah so i think that this was a very
pretty game and uh
i mean just queen b queen b8 i'm not
gonna give any chances
and she i believe she resigned here
because while the rook is falling
um no actually queen b2 was the easiest
way because queen b2
i'm just shuttering mate in one um
if rook a1 the problem is that again
you're giving your opponent chances to
fix the position queen b5 and then what
are you going to do your rookie is
kind of misplaced and the king can't run
away
there was a question on queen d5 but
then again the queen is misplaced
because now i can actually go for queen
b2 with idea queen b5 checkmate
even if queen c6 now i can just go the
other way
i remember i looked at this in the game
it was a very interesting
few minutes to just imagine different
mating ones
and you can't really go there anymore
because just queen a4
see if you go back you lose c4 if not b5
is falling
so this is another lovely game that i
played
that i got such a great comments about
it very proud of it
i want to really quickly show you the
position
i know all right i'm just going to show
a
very tiny position that i had against
talia
she's a very dear friend of mine
besides all the horrible mistakes that i
made
so in this position actually this this
got really funny because
i was trying to mate her
and uh she made a mistake and i actually
got a better position and i messed it up
so this is the game that i told you that
i cried after
because i um like i should have taken
take check the king goes away and king
e5 and i should be able to win this end
game
but i played c5 first and then i got
myself into this
end game with the bishop versus two
pawns and we saw how dangerous this can
be actually
i think this was a game that so wesley
won against london
um yesterday i might be wrong so please
feel free to
um check that and correct me but anyways
i made a mistake and i
got myself into this endgame and i
missed my chances to win as well also i
was i had
very few seconds on the clock anyways
but yeah this got sad here like i should
have played king e7
but anybody who knows me knows that i'm
not exactly the best when it comes to
theoretical chess
i'm very good at practical chess so
yeah no that was a sad point
all right let's just uh i want to talk
about the game against tatif because
that was a very good game
she was very generous and gave me a lot
of opportunities
i think she kind of had to because she
had to play for win because
if she won we would be tied for third
but if she didn't win
then i i mean if even if we drew i would
have sold third
so i guess it was a situation for her
that winning
or like drawing or losing didn't make a
difference so she was going all in
but i would really like to get um get
her
point on this i'll probably not contact
any of my opponents besides liking their
pictures on instagram and facebook
for um for a while i'll give them a week
or two
yeah all right so this game
anybody who knows tatev knows tato does
not play knight of six
so the day before this she actually
played this bishop before line
and um on a different day not today
because i'm already probably going to
run a little bit late
uh we are going to talk a little deeper
about the french opening and i will
i might show you what i have prepared
in this line i don't think i'm playing
tata again for a while so
should be fine i can spill my
preparations
um so yeah bishop g5
uh sorry bishop b4 is what
she usually plays
pretty much all the time but in this
game she played knight have six and i
was like
huh either she has some really deep
preparation or she really takes me for
an idiot
i would like to think it was the first
one but
i don't think i'll never know um
so we got into this position and
uh as i just mentioned i
didn't really know what to do i don't
have that much of a
big um i don't really have
that much of a theoretical foundation
when it comes
to um openings
or in the games oh god well i mean when
i don't play competitive chess as much
it kind of gets a little um dusty so i
mean i know that the general ideas but i
know
i don't know exactly the best moves to
do the most common moves that people do
i do know that knight f3 is the most
common one
but um i didn't really want to
go for that because i thought she would
know it better than i did
so i just want queen d3 so anybody who
has seen my game against irina
knows that i did that as well when um
i didn't know what to do against her so
i just played queen d3
queen editor is a fun move to play when
you don't know what to do put your queen
on d3 you always work stuff
uh i am reading the chat and there is a
question about can opponents be
friends well i don't really see me and
tata of his opponents or me and talia
because i don't play competitive chess
so they don't really have to see me as
like a danger actually
let me rephrase that after this
tournament but i mean i don't really
have that much chess
goals in mind i'm not i'm not thinking
about
winning the youth championship next year
or like doing this doing that
so i'm not i don't know
um okay so i don't want to keep you guys
longer so i'm just gonna
talk a little faster and i might be
ignoring the chat purposefully
for some reasons um all right
so in this position in this game uh i
think it was a very
interesting way to continue because i
know what i'm doing i'm going to do long
castle i'm probably going to
throw in an f4 and just put this knight
on
e5 and we'll see what happens next so
that was kind of my
idea and uh tata
oh this is funny according to the
engines f4 was a weird weird weird move
because she should have played b5 here
ah yeah makes sense because b5 b4 then
your knight is on b6 if i go knight a4
you have a decent attack
but i think i confused her with f4
and she just went knight f6 which was
not the best move i think b5
or queen c7 would be more logical the
knights on f6 isn't really doing much
to be honest and knight f3 she played b5
well here uh keep in mind
that um in this tournament at this point
in the tournament this is the last round
and i um i already had the knowledge
that
even if i um lose this game
i'm still tied for third and i was kind
of
very happy inside about it but then i
hadn't this is the game
that my cat was being
little um beep
and he wasn't very um
calm and as he was before and he was
just constantly meowing and asking for
tension and jumping
up and down and
so um anyways uh this this is that
famous cat game
if you want to refer to that and so
without a play b5
like i remember i was like oh god she's
starting her attack because tata also
has a very specific
style and this position is not her style
she likes to attack she likes to get
tactical she likes to have a good active
game
so do i and and this this wasn't her
game
this was a very poor choice of opening
for from her side
uh whoever prepared her i don't think
that was a um
that was the best way to go but again it
was a very um
life or death situation for her because
either she would win and she would
be tied for third or she would draw or
lose and i would get third
so my cat is a he
okay so oh yeah my cat knew all the
moves was
with meowing that was a i really wish
that was true
ah i wish i could actually understand my
cats
besides the fact that when he meows i
know he's annoyed at me
um how can you play practical
chess uh i don't know how to answer that
honestly it came as
with maturity for me and with laziness
that i did not want to calculate
so in this position she went for b4 i
mean i have
only one choice i got to put that knight
on a4
queen d5 well it wants to take whoops
wants to take a2 so again i have two
choices either king me1 or b3 i think
actually king b1 was a better choice but
i went for b3 because i wanted to keep
some room open
for my knight my cat is a gm at being
huge
that is true um so after b3
she played queen e4
i remember in this position i
i spent so much time thinking whether or
not i should take it whether or not i
should like
play somewhere with the queen like what
should i do because
uh as i told you before end games are
not my strongest suits
i don't feel as comfortable in end games
as i do when my coins are on where the
queens are on the board
so um i think that's why it was such a
hard choice for me to make and i just
find queen d2
um because again as i just said
i unless you really force me i'm not
gonna exchange coins man we exchange
coins
well you already have advantage so queen
d2
knight d5 and here i actually apparently
made a
mistake i took knight takes c6
uh computer says the g3 was the best
move but i did not
feel it over the board i actually not
think about g3 in this position
oh wait actually that's not correct i
thought about g3 and i thought about
bishop
something like with like bishop d3 or
something
and i thought this was an interesting
choice but
i wanted to try to see
i actually have no idea why i didn't do
that
i have no apps absolutely no idea why i
did not play g3
ah maybe i didn't like queen e3 huh
but could i take out that just take it
over here
well ah bishop b7 and then this gets
funky
interesting as you can see i have not
really checked this game before with the
i knew that g3 was suggested but anyways
um
so my thought process in the game was
okay i'm gonna take this
uh if you take queen four now that's the
one in the game i can't play that
actually that looks pretty
uh good it it doesn't present too many
issues oh maybe i shouldn't have taken
this was what i was going for
i wanted to have this knight against the
bishop and
i would do like a g3 get the bishop i
thought this was a decent
um decent position
so after knight c6 she made an
inaccuracy and she played bishop d6 she
should have taken over here
after bishop decents i had already
calculated this
ha surprise i'll calculate managed to
calculate a little
um i knew i was gonna play g3 and if
take i'm gonna definitely play
bishop b5 and after that well
the queen e4 seems to be the only move
so i
knew um i knew where i was going for
so i knew up until this position and i
remember i
spent a great deal of time when i was
planning g3 thinking about this position
because rookie won
i realized if i play rookie one there is
bishop f4 apparently
bishop f4 is not the best move for black
black has an a6 or something
i don't know about that but i just saw
bishop before
and i realized i do not want to get into
this position
however good this looks nope nope nope
um so i had to so i had to figure out
how to stop it
and then i figured out okay 95
check you move the king then i have
rookie one so it was a matter of
um just figuring out the right move
order
and it was kind of funny because if you
look at uh you don't see the time i
think
but right now on my clock i had three
minutes and 25 seconds
and when i choose chose to play knight
e5 i have like three minutes and
49 seconds so i made that choice within
like 20-ish seconds
and also when i played the move g3
i went from eight minutes to three
minutes and
49 seconds so i'm saying this because
i'm trying to show you that i had
already calculated that i had already
set my mind on g3 queen takes h1
bishop b5 pretty immediately knight e5
pretty immediately and then rookie one
so i had already
had this move sequence in my mind
because i got some questions that were
like so why did you spend so much time
on g3 and i was like
because i was actually calculating for
once
all right um i'm gonna stop uh
with trying to discourage you from
calculating
um uh
okay so she played knight c3 and i
realized well if i take it the knight
takes on the night stacking my queen and
i really don't want to calculate
especially because i had only three
minutes on my clock so i just played
bishop c6
oh i wanted to also mention this um if
you actually go back and watch the
actual commentary on youtube um
so i was doing this thing i don't know
if it's it's a good idea for everybody
or not but
i wanted to see my opponent's faces
so i had this like little setup that's
um so we were using skype and
zoom so i had like zoom setup and on the
right side
and i had skype set up on the left side
so i
i continuously look to see how my
opponents are doing
and full disclosure uh one of my
opponents was sharing
her screen so i i could kind of see that
and i saw that like she was touching
like
like trying to play like a queen
somewhere i think that was with krisa
i might be wrong but i i remember that
so i was trying to be a little um have a
little fun with the camera angles for
myself
so uh i saw that when i played this move
g3 tata was eating something and on
skype i saw her
her face went oh and i was like oh i got
you
and uh yeah so um
i don't know if that's good idea for
everybody i don't think
i don't think everybody likes to
actually analyze their opponents but
i liked it and i wanted to do it so
anyways
um here i knew that i was i had a better
position
and so i kind of wanted to just try to
maximize it and bishop c6 looked
look the part bishop c6 i'm tagging your
queen you gotta take this and i'm
attacking
your brook and i'm going to win your
pawn
sounds perfect to me okay you're
attacking my knight gotta move it
attacking my queen gotta move it and i
wanna have one move threats
my lovely one move threats still one
move threats
and i knew that i'm much better here but
i had like 40 seconds on my clock and i
was deeply deeply trying to avoid
calculating like
you have no idea how much i was trying
to run away from calculating
and um so i was like if i take queen f6
the king goes up i have chick but if the
king goes to c8
then i probably don't have this maybe
queen c6
and i was just like no i don't want to
calculate um so
i just point d6 my thought process was
d6
i'm leaving it up to you because i want
to checkmate in one
so how do you want to get out of this
and
she took it because funny enough if she
goes king see it it does not work
because well if you move the king your
rook falls if you move the rope
you get checkmated so i really enjoyed
this
the aspect of lazy chess maybe that
should that should be the title of
this uh video how to play
lazy chess um
this is actually a super winning just
have to not
lose your night so you just have to
throw in some checks throw in some
checks
and save the night and she actually
resigned here
and oh yeah ben simon found that
ah this was not the exact uh thank you
ben but this wasn't the
exact moment this is when she resigned
my face
um but yeah that's
g3 face tata face was very
um very interesting ah this is the cat's
picture
cat's image haha video
i had one minute on the clock and
this son of me just kept on
coming and just and like that laptop
over there is where the arbiter was
seeing
and i didn't want avatar to think
anything differently even though of
course
i didn't place the cat there but just i
i wanted to like have
everything covered so i was like okay
cat you gotta go
and yeah that was a very cute
um thing but if he made me lose this
game there would be no tuna for him or
two weeks
yeah thank you this was a very very um
amazing event for me definitely one of
my biggest accomplishments
uh at least in recent years because i
haven't really been playing competitive
chess
but yeah this was a very um great event
for me i
definitely owe it at least
to a very big extent to the
san plus chess club well because first
of all they invited me to organize
events but second of all the fact that
they um
kind of uh i thought i've been teaching
chess
for them pretty much all through uh this
year was a very
very um very helpful for me just because
you know how they say you don't know how
you don't know the material as well
until you teach it
well that happened to me i feel like i
actually understand
chess better and the different aspects
that it does
when i teach it so i do love teaching
and i apparently does help my game but
also my opponents very very helpful so
um i do believe that i was very lucky as
well
so with that um
i'm gonna go and celebrate a little bit
but uh thank you guys for
uh watching my streams and being with me
throughout all these events
make sure to keep watching the men's us
championship
that's going to be a fun one too and all
right
this was perfect thank you everybody
have a great rest of your night
you